all right so the second trailer for The
Dark Knight Rises I was waiting for
Warner Brothers to officially release it
before I talked about it so now they
have so now I will so the last trailer
didn't show us much of anything except
Jim Gordon alike this trailer shows us a
bit more than that so this trailer
starts out Michael Caine is doing his
monologue whenever Michael Caine doesn't
monologue it's awesome he's pretty much
like you're as important to me as you
were to your parents dude so you know I
think you're alright paraphrasing but
you know you are as precious to me as
you were to your own mother and father I
swore to them that I would protect you
and I happened and the trailer tells you
that it's peacetime all the Joker
problems are all gone it's peace it's
good but it shows you also that behind
the scenes Bane's making a plan and that
[ __ ] is gonna burn the city to the
ground the high rises as Bane would say
then he shows what I didn't expect to
see and that was Catwoman or at least
Selina Kyle with the masquerade ball
mask that looks like a cat and I was
hoping that she would have like a
sexiness to her voice and she really
does in this trailer I was like all
right sweet Catwoman sexy voice good but
she's also whispering
so she pulls it off when she's
whispering I just hope she doesn't have
to whisper for the entire movie because
that would be strange The Dark Knight
Rises would officially be the movie with
the strangest voice as ever and Catwoman
sound like she looks like an antihero or
anything like that solid she's like oh
she's antihero she's not with Bane she's
kind of a love interest with Batman she
looks like she's working with Bane and
she's a [ __ ] she's hot though I mean
seriously this is one scene where she's
walking like Audrey Hepburn I have no
problem with that
not that veins impress cuz Bane's like
yeah whatever and that is the coolest
scene in this trailer everyone who I've
shown this trailer to at this part
they're all like whoa and that is Bane
blowing up the football field that's
right touchdown yeah those people died
that's just a fact and then Bane has the
best line in the trailer Gotham is
alright so in my video on the six-minute
prologue I said that Bane was really
hard to understand I like how his voice
sounds I just don't like the fact that
he's hard to understand but in this
trailer right here I can understand him
perfectly
his voice is more bassy in this trailer
than he was in the six-minute prologue
so I think this has refined audio
I hope he's like this for the entire
movie cuz that's a pretty menacing voice
yeah and then after that it's just a
montage of the Bane champ meets action
meets fighting meets things blowing up
meets the batwing what interested me is
it shows Bruce Wayne with a beard like
he's in this really shitty prison or
something and at first I was like is
that like a flashback from when he was
rolling around with criminals when he
was in that one jail at the beginning of
Batman Begins but I don't think it is so
between Catwoman's monologue and Bane's
militia going through this really rich
house I'm pretty sure it's Wayne Manor
and pulling people out from under
dressers and whatnot is it like occupy
Gotham or something like that like they
snatch up all the rich people and Gotham
and throw them in this really shitty
Gotham guantánamo Gotham ton MO I guess
while Bane burns Gotham to the ground I
don't know but that's what the teaser
trailer should do it should get you to
talk about this kind of stuff you know
make you theorized and then I get
excited for the movie because it's just
an awesome trailer right so a theory on
the Dark Knight Rises what is going on
here is Bruce Wayne thrown into a prison
is this a flashback of when he was like
rolling with criminals before Batman
began
I want to hear your theories theorize
the hell out of this trailer comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
I had to put the title in there because
it's epic too
[Music]